مبارزه مثيره على المسرح الدولي جعلت
اوكرانيا بين خطابين عشيه الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب من موسكو تحدث الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ومن وارسو الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن خطابان متضادان في كل شيء الا في
تاكيدهما ان الحرب مستمره بل هي قد ترتاد
في عامها الثاني مربعات جديده من التصعيد
وعلى نحو اكثر التعارضا سرد الخطابان
تقييمين مختلفين لعام مضامنا الحرب كان
بالنسبه لبايدن صمودا تاريخيا لكييف
والديمقراطيه الغربيه الراسخه ومن وجهه
نظر بوتين كان عاما حافلا باخفاقات الغرب
في النيل من روسيا واقتصادها
الغرب يستخدم اوكرانيا راس حربه وميدان
تدريب ضد روسيا ويحاول تغيير سير المعركه
بزياده الامدادات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
وكلما ازداد الامداد بمنظومات الاسلحه
الغربيه لاوكرانيا كلما اضطررنا لابعاد
التهديدات اكثر عن حدودنا
لقد كانت سنه استثنائيه تميزت بوحشيه غير
عاديه من القوات الروسيه والمرتزقه لقد
ارتكبوا جرائم ضد الانسانيه دون خجل او
رافه استهدف المدنيين بالقتل والتدمير
هي مبارزه مشحونه بالرموز والدلالات تذكر
باشد ساعات الحرب البارده توترا خاصه
وانها استحضرت كل عناصر تلك المرحله
الصعبه على اوروبا والعالم
فوارسو عاصمه بولندا التي تحدث منها
الرئيس الامريكي هي نفسها التي كانت ذات
يوم مقر حلف وارسو حلف المنظومه الشرقيه
انذاك في مقابل حلف الناتو المظله
العسكريه للحلفاء هل اراد بوتين اثاره
الغرب اكثر بتعليق اهم اتفاقيه معه ام كان
قراره فعلا لحمايه بلاده
مضطر اليوم للاعلان عن تعليق روسيا
مشاركتها في معاهده تقليص الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه لا ننسحب من
المعاهده بل نعلق مشاركتنا ويجب ان تكون
وزاره الدفاع وشركه الاستعداد لاختبار
الاسلحه النوويه اذا بدات الول المتحده
بذلك
ثم هل تعمد بايدن هذه المره ان يكون في
منطقه الحرب وغير بعيد من موسكو امعانا في
تحدها مسار رحلته من واشنطن الى ومنها الى
وارسو يمكن ان يحيل الى ذلك في لحظه بدات
فيها حرب اوكرانيا اشبه بحرب امريكيه
روسيه راسها بوتين وبايدن وهو ما قد يجعل
وقفها
رهنا بايديهما ايضا